buonasera a tutti but now and good
evening con benoit sun fire o a tardi
potremmo diventante league ma veniamo al
dunque
io guardo poco la televisione ma
ultimamente mi è capitato qualche volta
di accenderla e devo dire che ho visto
dei grandi orrori che mi hanno sconvolto
ogni volta che c'era la televisione vedo
uccisioni guerre attentati
cadaveri sparsi sulle nostre spiagge
ma cosa che stringe il cuore una volta
mi chiamavano clandestini adesso
arrivato l'ordine di chiamarli profughi
avevano anche fatto delle leggi per
criminalizzarli i profughi adesso
non li vuole ancora nessuno però li
chiamiamo profughi in italia le cose
cambiano nome ma rimangono sempre le
stesse
prendo l'autobus è solo autobus mi trovo
davanti un paio di persone una coppia
videntemente con una abbastanza
abbronzata che parla fitto fitto io sono
curioso di capire da dove vengono
finalmente colgo una parola che mi
sembra di riconoscere di quasi
portoghese non è portoghese di
portogallo non è anche brasiliano forse
vengono da capo verde chi lo sa
sono molto orgoglioso di questa mia
capacità anche senza parlare lingue di
saperli riconoscere ma in quel momento
la mia attenzione è captata da una
signora la patrona che squillante mente
il palo al telefonino e dice qualche
cosa in una lingua che sicuramente una
lingua slava ma non è il russo
potrebbe essere ucraino l'area dalla
badante cela
poco più in là ci sono due
ragazzi che sembra stiano litigando con
di brutto e in realtà sono due
marocchini si è evidentemente i
marocchini sembra sempre che ritirino
quando partner stanno sorridendo
insomma
sono orgoglioso di questa mia capacità e
cerco di
coinvolgere il mio vicino che non mi
sembra altrettanto entusiasta pensare
che neanche lui parla italiano
fatti a un certo punto sbotta dire stimo
rukaj che vagano a col ruolo
ha però questo non è italiano però il
bolognese quindi e locale va bene ma
questo innesca un processo che coinvolge
altri personaggi sull'autobus
c'è per esempio uno che interviene
dicendo brutta gente tutti spacciatori e
portano via il lavoro agli italiani
allora loraine inserisco dico perché
solo gli italiani devono spacciare
e
quello se ne va via sdegnato mi sembra
di aver tradito la patria quando quando
dico queste cose
mi ricordo una volta anni fa a
una riunione del quartiere savena c'era
uno che tutto nava contro il fatto che
in fondo gli ammazzamenti c'era una
moschea dice c'è uno spaccio tenendo in
quella zona
che io gli risposi
anche in piazza verdi c'è uno spaccio e
c'è la chiesa di san giacomo maggiore
non capisco il nesso tra le due cose
mi riguarda male perché ho interrotto
infettiva mente sono stato maleducato ma
quando comincia a dire bisogna
restituire quei locali al comune perché
bisogna riaprire le scuole ci sono tanti
bambini nel quartiere non resisto alzo
la mano al fascio dare la parola e nico
sono daccordo sulla riapertura della
scuola perché ci sono immigrati che
fanno tanti fili la gente mi guarda con
un po di
sussiego però c'è qualcuno che si
diverte
sorride un pochino ma noi italiani siamo
brava gente non siamo razzisti
su tutti fratelli tutti uguali siamo
certo magari quelli che sanno la pelle
così scura non sono tanto uguali e se
hanno la pelle scura magari qualcosa
la ragione ci sarà
noi siamo un popolo di santi poeti
navigatori
siamo eredi di una tradizione culturale
bellissima greco romana cattolica lei va
sempre in chiesa la domenica si accosta
i sacramenti no
per però legge la divina commedia a non
si intende di teatro ho capito
insomma siamo un popolo di pieno di
contraddizioni quando totti fa un gol
siamo pronti a sbandierare il tricolore
come i disperati poi quando in realtà
sentiamo parlare una persona con un
accento meridionale
allora diventiamo padani e questi
che va dalla casa loro tutti
vedevano andare a casa loro vogliamo che
questa gente non resti qui da noi non li
vogliamo perché ci mettono in crisi sono
diversi da noi via fanno delle cose
strane anno lingue strane usi strani
che vadano a casa loro che gli islamici
soprattutto vadano a casa loro gli
islamici la dalla casa loro io mi
ribello a questo punto perché dico
innanzitutto se parliamo italiano non si
dice gli islamici perché islamica un
aggettivo che si riferisce a cose si
dice musso una roma a parte questo io
che cosa faccio dove vado sono già a
casa mia la costituzione mi garantisce
la libertà di culto
c'è un articolo 3 che lo dice ah beh la
costituzione ora di cambiarla sì è vero
perché era invecchiata
veramente non siamo neanche riusciti
ancora implicare la tuta e il ros sempre
stato convinto che tre perché i nostri
uomini politici avessero fatto un ottimo
lavoro con la costituzione ma cambiamo
la eliminiamo la libertà di culto
cacciamo gli islamici poi cacceremo via
gli ebrei e zingari
handicappati
qualcosa che ho già sentito da qualche
parte ma la storia non ci insegna green
che la storia non è maestra di vita in
realtà e nessuno la vuole come maestra
di vita perché tutti sanno sbagliare da
soli senza bisogno di aiuto e poi in
genere la gente dice a me questo non
potrebbe capitare mai
penso ancora quei due ai ragazzi
marocchini sull'autobus quando andiamo
alle feste multietniche mangiare cous
cous insieme ci fa sentire tutti i buoni
fratelli però devono tornare anche loro
a casa loro non importa se col e con
loro lavoro pagano le pensioni e gli
italiani che scolora lavoro pagano le
tasse che gli italiani evadono che fanno
mestieri che gli italiani non vogliono
fare
soprattutto a dimentichiamoci che
vengono non soltanto per lavorare
vengono soltanto erano soprattutto per
sopravvivere perché lì nelle loro case
non possono più stare forse non ci sono
neanche più le loro casini in alcune
situazioni
vengono perché
possono morire da un momento all'altro
mentre noi produciamo tante armi e noi
usiamo a causa della strada li
rivendiamo agli altri c'è un'intera
industria delle armi che fa morire
migliaia di persone in giro per il mondo
loro vengono perché i loro bambini
quando giocano nel prato non rischiano
di trovare una mina antiuomo che gli
scoppia in faccia
e noi nel 94 quando ci fu lo imbarco
sulle applicazioni delle mine antiuomo
abbiamo visto una azienda intera la
valsella che è fallita perché non avevo
più fatturato sufficiente
quando è fallita si è scoperto che
avevano mandato illegalmente via
singapore 9 milioni di mine antiuomo in
iraq
i dirigenti lo misero furono processati
e naturalmente assolti
noi cosa possiamo dire a questo punto
che è vero che il problema e ognuno a
casa sua se la casa ci fosse in realtà
il problema dell'immigrazione negli
ultimi anni è diventato molto molto
complesso
estremamente complesso
esattamente il complesso perché questa
gente viene da paesi diversi e lingue
diverse tradizioni diverse non vengono
un unico paese vengono da 170 197 paesi
diversi si sono residenti in italia che
vengono addirittura da posti che si
chiamano palau vanuatu tuvalu nauru non
molti credo sappiano dove si trovano che
se queste località
in italia ci sono attualmente 5 oltre 5
milioni di stranieri residenti
noto per cento della popolazione
italiana
e non è strano che i bambini nelle
scuole
possono essere il 10 per cento di una
classe ormai perché io naturalmente gli
stranieri fanno più figli di noi
quello che ci dimentichiamo però di
ricordare è che nel mondo esistono 80
milioni di persone
oriunde italiani 80 milioni di persone
che hanno nonno o meno di origine
italiana o italiano
e che nel 1860 quando ci fu l'unità
d'italia la popolazione italiana della
circa 30 milioni
fino alla fine del 6 colucci che furono
dieci milioni di persone che mira erano
in america brasile argentina uruguay e
stati uniti è una pagina di storia che
se i nostri libri di scuola non si legge
questo
anche se dobbiamo non della solidarietà
a queste persone per semplice fattore
umano
dobbiamo anche cercare di ricordarci
che la solidarietà non si esprime
attraverso gli aiuti umanitari
non si esprime attraverso le missioni di
pace gli aiuti umanitari servono
sentirci buoni e sentirci coinvolti poi
lasciano il tempo che trovano le
missioni di pace le compiono soldati
armati fino ai denti con i carri armati
non ho capito che ma ci sia quella con
le armi ma insomma
quello che veramente sarebbe importante
avere una scuola diversa avere una
scuola che rispondesse ai bisogni di una
un dialogo di una corretta informazione
e di un interscambio che porti all
integrazione di queste persone
perché forse abbiamo dimenticato la
differenza che c'è tra
integrazione e assimilazione abbiamo
dimenticato quello che è la differenza
tra tolleranza e rispetto
nelle nostre scuole
sappiamo ci sono tanti insegnanti
precari e comunque gli insegnanti sono
sottopagati mentre le spese militari
nessuno ne mette in discussione ogni
volta che c'è da fare un discorso sulla
scuola pare che i soldi non ci siano mai
e la scuola via e c'è bisogno di una
nuova dimensione di un nuovo modo di
confrontarsi con queste realtà
in realtà quello che noi vediamo è che
la storia si fa in modo sbagliato si fa
la storia a partire dall europa si fa la
storia a partire da quelle che sono le
situazioni che ci sono in europa nei
paesi dove gli europei hanno terminato
le popolazioni locali
nelle nostre scuole cosa sappiamo per
esempio di quello che è avvenuto in
messico mille anni fa chi c'era
si parla della civiltà maya e duemila
anni fa in cina chi comandava quando
c'era all'interno dell'iran
e 4000 anni fa in egitto
quando già avevano costruito le grandi
piramidi
quando si fa matematica scuola se dice
per esempio che
il
quando studiamo al gip era quando
studiamo trigonometria quando impariamo
i logaritmi
impariamo delle cose che sono state
inventate da matematici arabi
e che quando faremo di astronomia i
nostri astronomi usano 200 nomi di
stelle arabi
quando parliamo della rivoluzione
copernicana ci dimentichiamo che
ci fu un astronomo 500 anni prima di
keplero che però scriveva in arabo
purtroppo
che si chiamava alberoni e che non
sfigurerebbe accanto a copernico accanto
a
galilei
tutti noi sappiamo che è successo nel
1492 cristoforo colombo scopre l'america
ma cos'ha scoperto non lo so perché
c'era da 40mila anni e popolazioni che
abitavano in quei posti
scopre l'america
ma non lo sa perché credevo di essere
arrivato in cina
ma quanti sanno che i 1.260 ci va bene
una
battaglia famosa in altre parti del
mondo che ha cambiato le sorti d'europa
le orde mongole dei nipoti di gengis
khan
erano arrivate quasi sulle soglie del
mediterraneo le spiagge del mediterraneo
si sarebbero imbarcati avrebbero
intrapreso la conquista al saccheggio
dell'italia e dell'europa
furono fermati solo a in giallo da un
sultano mamelucco che si chiamava cultus
che cambiò le sorti del mondo
chi ne ha mai parlato nelle scuole
io credo che questo tipo di
rapporto nella scuola dove ogni persona
possa avere il diritto di parlare e
sentirsi un essere umano considerato e
interessanti ad ascoltare porterebbe un
interscambio di verso un'auto un altro
modo di rapportarci con chi è diverso da
noi
arricchendo entrambi perché anche noi
impareremo a capire meglio chi siamo noi
stessi qual è la nostra cultura e capire
che queste grandi differenze nel mondo
non ci sono anche perché il mondo è
diventato un villaggio globale ormai è
un villaggio globale dove
tutto interessa tutti perché
globalizzazione non deve significare
omologazione culturale come denunciava a
50 anni fa pasolini il rischio
dell'omologazione culturale che
spariscano tutte le culture e vengano
assimilati da un'unica cultura dominante
abbiamo imparato che
la biodiversità è un valore necessario
per preservare il nostro pianeta del
food nel futuro per portarlo a una
situazione
vivibile anche per i nostri figli
quello che succede nel resto del mondo
ci riguarda noi personalmente come sarà
il mondo di domani riguarda ciascuno di
noi individualmente personalmente se in
sierra leone accade qualcosa anche se
non sappiamo dove sia la sierra leone
sicuramente avrà delle ricadute anche
sul nostro modo di vivere
non sarà che questa biodiversità che
abbiamo accettato e che consideriamo uno
positivamente
sia qualche cosa che deve farci
accettare anche l'importanza della
diversità delle culture e mantenimento
alla diversa dalle cultura nel mondo
grazie